oh and kinsey to piggyback on sandy how
do you calm a crowd
that just wants to visit with friends
and didn't necessarily come for comedy
oh yeah that's a that's a toughy that's
a toughy
kinsey if there's people there that
weren't necessarily there for
comedy that's a that's a tough
dicey situation because they are patrons
of
the venue what you can do is
politely ask them to be quiet and make
them
feel welcome don't make them feel like
an outsider for being there and not
knowing there was going to be comedy
you can address everyone and you don't
even have to point out people
specifically
even if it is just two people you can
address everyone
as for those of you who didn't know
it was going to be comedy we're so
excited to have you all anyway
thank you so much for taking a chance on
us and hanging out with us during this
comedy show
even if you weren't expecting it to
happen if you don't like the show
that's your right please just keep it to
yourselves you know comedy is a very
difficult art form and all these comics
put in a lot of work
to be here so if you could please just
keep your table talk to a minimum keep
the volume low
and respect the comics on the show and
get like
a consensus from them of like
can we do that and kind of get them
to like agree and applaud and be like
yeah let's let's do this we're all in
this together
so that's a good way to get
those crowds that aren't expecting
comedy on your side
just by being genuine and authentic with
them and talking to them as people and
not as someone on stage yelling into a
mic
but really just addressing them and like
talking to them and letting them know
what's happening
even though in sympathizing or
empathizing i don't know which word my
liberal arts degree didn't teach me the
difference
but really using one of those
empathizing
words to just level with them and be
like here's the situation
we'd love to have you be a part of this
and if you don't want to be please just
do be respectful
of the show in the comics and speak
quietly
thanks for watching this clip if you
found these tips helpful and you want to
get involved in our hosting workshop
go into the show description and request
to join
our hot breath pro facebook group if
you're looking to level up your comedy
that is the group for you